Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Darkest Dungeon. (smh mark)
Now I've played this before, but only the early early demo
In fact, this is a new version that was worked on by the same guy that made Joy of Creation
Nikson, or at least he worked on part of it... Or a lot of it..
I think he did the animation for this one, but either way  *spoopy noise in the background*
This is the new,,,,
*slowly and unsurely* Dark Dun...
Dark Deception? Never mind. I got that wrong. Dark Deception! Dark Deception...
It is done.
Now, my faith lies in darkness.
Okay, I don't know if that's the best place for it. But okay.
Oh, hiii :O
*You have subtitles down there...*
. . .
HeHeHeHello, how are you?
BIERCE
Oh, hi! Hello. How are you?
BIERCE: Oh, another one! How nice to have some company again.
Ahhh, I suppose yes.
BIERCE: Come over here, let's have a look at you.
I'm kind of already here. I don't know if I need to come any closer..
BIERCE: You disappoint me, love.
What the hell?!
BIERCE: You really do.
I just got here!
BIERCE: So many fears.
No!
BIERCE: So many desires...
Yeah, okay I can't deny that one.
BIERCE: I thought you'd be bigger.
Okay, you---
*TRIGGERED*
Bigger.... I thought you'd be bigger
Huh?
Oh, Okay
Yeah, it sounds about right
Okay, all right, well you don't have to hit the nail too hard on the head there ("i CoUlD hAvE bEeN An EnGiNeEr")
HAH!
Here you are~ (spoopy darkiplier-like voice)
No, I don't like this dominatrix thing that's going on I'm not into that
So if we could just skate on by that before- before something awakens in me that I don't want to (whats was that MARK?)
Oh?..
They- wha- Oh Okay
Okay
I- *confused stuttering*
I don't know if I want that. That doesn't sound good. Also are you the announcer from Team Fortress 2?
Are you is this like your moonlight job? Just being creepy kind of vampire lady going on. Telling me I'm not BIG enough ;)
Fine then... Buttroom... Bierce's buttroom.
HO-
Hello
You're tall!
What is my wish? I don't even know what my wish is
Okay, why did I come here in the first place? I'm sorry that I'm only eye level with your boobs!
Clock's ticking, hang on. Let me get a look at this amazing architecture that you got in here. Love the head of the statue!
It's awfully nice. Hey, don't look at me like that
Why you being all-. Oh god. I thought your head was gonna turn all the way around. Oh, it's so pretty!
Why am I here? All right. Okay, I'll go into this. Man, they really revamped this crazy- Okay
*AHH*
I don't know if that was yawn or you're just surprised that I came close.
I don't like it.
D- OHHH
That's do-
*concerned sounds*
Wimbly, Wombly, Wimbly, Wombly.(WTF? xD) Ah now, that's what I call a door, or a lack of a door...
That's what I call a hole in the wall
Oh, okay. Boy they beefed this game up good. Hello monkey business, oh
*concerning chuckles*
I remember the monkeys. Oh, I remember the monkeys indeed
Indeed
Yeah a little bit. Hey are you are you being all meta about the original game because that's pretty cool. Ring for service
*DING INTENSIFIES*
Hello? Service! I don't know why you'd pop out if he's gonna walk out like an elevator or something like that
Alright apparently nothing. Welcome breakfast and murder free until 10:00 a.m
So it cost money after 10:00 a.m. Do I have to pay for my own murder? Oh you are you are a bag of nightmares
*scared shouting*
Why did that scare me?! You are a shit that didn't scare me!!!  There's no evidence to the contrary! (can we get a replay on that?)
*R E P L A Y*
What are you gonna do the same don't you even think about it-
No
N-No
NO
well
This is an odd predicament, but I'm gonna go blindly forward
Hello friend. How are you doing? Good to see you
*horrifying shrieks from hell demon*
I'm sorry, I startled you friend
Oooo~
Okay... a bing bong? No?
All right, then. Well, that was fun. I'm glad I did that. I'm glad we all agreed that that was worth my time (yes, it was)
I'm glad that I'm here.
(I wouldn't be...XD)
Oh wait
*elevator dings*
*elevator doors opening*
Ah!
Perfect my ride. I'll just hop on in even though.... I was gonna go down wink wonk wink wonk
I don't like it. What have you got? Oh
Hey it's that statue I like!
Yes. Oh, no, those.
Oh
HMM!?
OH
*knocking*
HEY
Oh well listen lady...
Listen lady
Listen lady.
(listen linda, LiStEn)
Lady listen!
If there's one thing that I don't do its disappoint
I am the master of undisappointation. people always be satisfied when I walk in the room
It's like I do not try to get not
Satisfied challenge when I'm... around
Okay, so I gotta be somewhat organized about this, I remember what I played this before
Why is that happening?
That is a (bucky)? not bad shard streak. ahhh yai yai! Is there a-
*screaming*
Fight wait whoa. Whoa. Hey, whoa, not need not need not need. Nah need. Nah need( NANI?!?!)
nany de I mean they really
Beefed this up they beef this up a lot
AH- AH- NO- MONKEY!
I thought I could get that one there
Lady: How about you don't let them stab you in the face...
They didn't stab me in the face, they chewed my face off there's a big difference lady. Listen, if you want to get
Satisfied by me. Whoa. Huhuhu
I got a big Bonco
Hohoho
Alright then who's this
Let me in let me in please
Okay, so it said enemies were revealed but I don't see no enemies. What's the point of that? Oh
That's not good. That's not good. That's not good. That's not good. Okay, it's fine
There is the enemy but I don't know how long it's gonna be revealed like that
Oh, this is where I wass you can't catch me. You can catch me. Oh, you can catch me. Oh
You oh, oh you can catch me.
Oh boy
How long are the enemies gonna be revealed for cuz that's awfully handy
Help!
Help I'm warming up. Help I'm warm. Uh-Oh
Well, this doesn't sound good.
I wanna get a good look at ya. Get a good. Oh, I don't like the look at ya
I don't like the look a ya. I just wanted to see how ya look. Oh you're a charming fella ain't ya?
Oh, you're full of spunk ain't ya well, alright. You take care now. You have a good one
I know it's closing in. I'm aware of this. Oh, where am I now?
Well, I have no enemies revealed, which is probably a bad thing
*scared shouting*
NO!
That's a lot of okay well I'm dead.
Nobody liked you anyway.
Hey don't feed into my insecurities like that
I think that people probably like me a lot. My god, this is gonna be difficult
AAAH!! This gonna be difficult cuz they're coming to get me. Oh, I went the wrong way
I'm full of dick and piss and vinegar. Ohahh I'm so stupid
bad mark big ol dummy me am me am big dumb!
*shouting*
*while shouting* ME AM BIG DUMB
Okay, that's fine. I made it somehow. Hey yoiiiyoy
Me hoy minoy? No, oh, there was no one coming down that way. I thought there was... turns out there was not.
Uh oh, oh
That's too close for comfort. Oh
Ayyyye. Ayyyye,ayyyye.No bad touch. What is this? I hope it's good
I got it enemies stunned. Yeah, aw stupid you,haa. Get all stupid on you, huh?
You is too stupid to come get me stupid. Why you be so dumb you dumb stupid?
Huh, you're full of stupid and dumb you all. Oh wait. No are they not stupid? Are they not dumbed?
You're dumb and you stupid you dumb and stupid and dumb full of dumb.
Me am smart big smart with my big brain. (get the reference?) Oh here they come. Can I get another power-up that'd be... that be so nice.
Okay, I'm in trouble if I get cut off down this corridor for some reason.
Oh shit oh shit. Oh shit. Oh shit. Oh, we know they were probably coming. Yeah
That was very close. Okay, we're good. We're far away from them now. It's all Gucci baby all Gucci all day.
Oh you think you got me the an– Hey! I'm on fire
Okay, that's good
That's good. I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get this and then I'm gonna get you
Oh, you think you got me? You don't not me not today? Not me. Not today, not me not today
Not me. Not today. It's so funny to see a game
With with like kind of a a little bit of a silly premise. I mean it is it's a game a pac-man
But a terrifying game of pac-man at that
But it's funny to see a game like this come into a really really nice remake into it. And I mean, this is free
wop- shit bAH!
No, thank you. You right behind? Oh yeah, you are. I think they might be pissed off at me. Oh, yeah, they're pissed off
Well oooh shit. Oh, oh god. Oh, I have no idea where that is. Okay
Those are the last four I imagine I gotta get those and then I gotta get all the way back to the entrance
But thankfully I'm close to the entrance. So it's like I planned this out... planned this out... with my big brain... where? Where? Where? Where?
Please... don't... cut me off
Don't cut me off
Don't cut me off no, don't cut me off I said, please please be open path
I am
So fine, I am FINE
Yes
Go, why?
Whewwee
Who dares? I dare
I'm trying where's the portal?
Hey, hey listen, listen, buddy, I don't know who you're talking about! Wait, wait! Whoa!
Whoa. Whoa Oh
Bing bong
That was a little unnecessary you think Mr. Monkey Man
Again, I don't know who this lady is. And I don't know what she has to do with this guy-iii... That's pissed off
I AM RUUNIN' OKAY? I DIDN'T KNOW THAT WA-
HooOOLy SHIT!
I think there might be some kind of an escape
Mortal go through the portal and you ain't gonna get mortal no more.
*Weird santa laugh*
I escaped
That was nice. That was... secrets?
secrets?
Secrets? Ain't that a load of patootie. Oh level two, what does that even mean?
I don't even know what that means, but I got a lot of soul shards
That's a lot of people that died in that place, b-but I got 'em. Oh, hey. Hey, Bierce
You doing you so fierce Bierce. Oh you fierce Bierce. I like you fierce Bierce with your fierce-
uh, necklace
Ahh... Your friend's kind of a douche don't mean it's- Uh oh... hello hi, hi nice eye
Bierce!
Hmmm...
Okay. Now who am I gonna trust; the horrible disembodied veiny eye or the very nice attractive lady?
now *laughs*
the nice attractive ladies who seem to not be too concerned with my death are
Always to be trusted and I don't trust no door. I never trust a door with an eye on it
Doh okay alr-
mnae okay alright...and I will suffer
Oh and I wouldn't suffer from the monkeys
But yours can, I bet your powers have so much reach
Yes, ma'am
Yes, ma'am.
well
That's okay. I think muscle memory kicks in after a while
Malak all right
Or so the legend goes you wouldn't happened to have used this ring at some point
would you have have done that have you?
Guess you might have yes then
Yah yeet I suppose
Hello, lady my god...
Oh yes
I am- eight? Wait, but there's but there's ten portals... My god, you are
stunning lady. I am
So... okay, there's a weird yawn thing again... I am SO into you. Also, hey demon guy!
How are you doing?
Okay, I don't like that
All right. Well you keep watching pervert
ya weirdo
What are you doing lady? All right. Well anyway Bierce, hey listen, you know, I'd do anything for you and I mean
AnYtHiNg
Anyway so I'm gonna go on this porta-Ohhhh
Yeah, that's probably fine.
Yeah, let's go for it. Let's see what happens. It's cool.
I hate it. I hate it. I hate that. Nooooo!
It's all done
Noooooo
I can't believe that... that's but... you know, actually thankfully I think I'm okay with that because whatever I'm looking at in front of me
me right now is
Horrible. This is great. I can't believe they'd turn a concept like this into something really amazing
This is legiuhhhh...
No, thank you.
Oh God no. Oh my god, no!
EWEH *disgust*
Back! *laughter into cries of disgust*
My god Oh Bierce's Diaries? Oh hell yeah. Oh, but also Vince Livings, Nick "Nikson" Sita
Yeah! Daniel Koe, Peter Anderson, Vince Livings, Shun Kim
Pen Livings, Gabe Lopez, Melissa Sawicki, Sietske Wielsma, Marcus Williams, Yuri Dholakia... all these wonderful people
Thank you so much for working on this. I can't wait to see what comes next because this is some good stuff
You've got here! And the first part was free!
I imagine they'd probably charge something for this game because this is really nicely made. So hopefully it gets fully made sometime soon
So thank you everybody so much for watching. You can check out the game in the description below, and as always, I'll see you
in the next video.
Buh bye!
*Outro Music*